and then tomorrow I'm appearing at the
Jacob Javits Convention Center to debut
the kiss coffin now explain to me this
is your latest invention you've invented
everything wait a minute where do you
sit in a dark room and you come up with
these things you can literally be buried
with kiss now this is true
Gene you spent did you spend most of
your day inventing stuff don't you this
is his lab the kiss coffin the kiss you
know even more important than that did
you know that seven out of 10 kiss fans
when they pass away they actually
usually they leave behind a little bit
of money we're looking into a way to get
that money straight to kids
and split it up four ways now three
little four ways you're on crack
it's just Gene and Paul really no it's
not true everybody makes lots of money
at the end of the day the kiss coffin
sounds kind of morbid it does look it's
a real coffin very high class completely
waterproof I can't believe you didn't
bring one
there it's at the Javits Convention
Center but let me say something how much
does it cost it's going to be about 4
500 to 5 grand what is so special about
this car I'm glad you asked Robin go
ahead what do you do with the kids can
you be buried you can it's completely
waterproof you know in other words no no
bodily fluids are going to sleep and
everything but
you know really high five it's got kiss
all over it so even The Morbid stuff
aside you mean we're watching this is
the coffin you're right there in front
of them we're all over around them
inside outside the whole thing however
yes but here's the plus you can enjoy it
while you're alive Sunday you got the
guys over you're watching the ball game
open up the coffin grab a cool one
because babe it's a cooler let me
understand something I can put ice in
there it's a cooler that's what it
doubles what it really is yes and it can
be buried in it correct I mean I mean
there's nothing illegal about being
buried in a kiss coffin is there no
absolutely not it's a legal coffin God
will open the Pearly Gates much faster
right for actually it's it's never been
done before but for one billion dollars
I'm actually get in the casket with you
laughs